die pressekonferenz war eigentlich schon
zu ende und dann hat der
polizeipressesprecher noch mal das
podium betritt gesagt daher sei wohl
etwas voreilig gewesen
der staatsanwalt hatte vorher erklärt
dass es noch kein haftbefehl gegeben
habe weil die dame erst mal die frau
erst mal stabil sein muss so und dann
muss wohl zwischen ende der
pressekonferenz und ungefähr 25 sekunden
später dann tatsächlich die information
weitergeleitet worden sein das ist jetzt
ein haftbefehl gegen die mutter gibt
gehen die tatverdächtige und dass sie
sich jetzt auch schon in u-haft befindet
was der staatsanwalt jetzt noch nicht
wusste ob es in einem
justizvollzugskrankenhaus ist oder in
einer mine ja für frauen allerdings ist
das jetzt die meldung dass dann
wahrscheinlich der gesundheitszustand
sich auch wohl gebessert hat und jetzt
muss man halt mit ihr sprechen jetzt
muss es ein psychiatrisches gutachten
geben und jetzt kann man hoffentlich
damit beginnen die tat aus ihrer sicht
weiter aufzuklären
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren